[Music]
well it seems Selena Gomez won't have to
look any further yes after several years
of keeping her dating life out of the
spotlight Selena seems to have a new
love interest
an Insider tells us weekly Gomez has
been casually dating Drew Taggart from
the hip EDM Duo The Chainsmokers things
are reportedly going well for the
suspected couple who are keeping things
pretty low-key which is great news to
hear because as we know Selena is so
sick of that same old love
okay the Jokes Aside sources have
reported that the two are spending
quality time together enjoying date
nights like bowling and going to the
movies cute having to prepare are so
affectionate with one another and that
Selena can hardly keep her hands off
hand can't keep my hands to myself
now The Chainsmokers recently appeared
on the call her daddy podcast where Drew
appeared Charissa smitten when he
revealed that he's in a relationship but
he didn't disclose with who exactly uh
I'm in a relationship okay it's like
fairly new a couple months it's exciting
how'd you guys meet we got set up on a
date
a year ago and it was the worst day
either of us had ever been on not fun
yeah it was just like zero Vibes just
misconnection and didn't see each other
for I think like six months after that
and then last summer I just kept running
into each other and then the Bad Day
become became like a fun conversation
point and we like hit it off on like the
Fourth of July and then started hanging
out then-ish and August and then I
started dating I guess September
probably okay but get this that wasn't
the only breaking news The Chainsmokers
also confess they've had threesomes with
fans on multiple occasions and joke that
it was due to having to share a room how
often do people propose threesomes with
the two of you and how often have you
accepted through the account if it's
internationally
the first time
in Europe they have the two beds they
don't split them apart you know what I
mean like they literally have two
singles so it's like almost by Forest we
were forced that sounds crazy
but the European government because they
don't separate their beds